nice exposures sometimes they beat their
horns they could see on a big screen how
everyone was graduating they beat their
horns over the next two weeks guys 36
graduations are gonna be held there at
the Texas Motor Speedway 14,000 students
will get there would they get their
diplomas and the head of the speedway
says look I know it's not the graduation
they expected but they're going to be
able to have an adventure of their lives
are gonna be able to tell their kids
look the kids gonna where did you
graduate mom at the Texas Motor Speedway
it's going to be memorable it's really
good yeah I love that I think it's
actually a perfect metaphor because you
know in a NASCAR race the starting line
is also the finishing line in high
school is a finishing line but at the
same time you're starting again
the new race ladies and gentlemen start
your engines right I like it good
metaphor there all right my pick is a
hopeful story about someone who knows
firsthand the kind of economic hardship
that families can face at a time like
this at the moment the economic hardship
is caused by the pandemic and many
people are being pushed closer to
homelessness
even before the coronavirus get this
some 38 million Americans were living in
poverty and more than six million were
considered at risk of becoming
completely homeless but there are plenty
of people even in a deep crisis like
this who have lived through similar
difficulties and we went out and we
found one such person because we really
think you're gonna love where she ended
up and I know she may be familiar to
some of our longtime viewers autumn hope
Johnson doesn't need the news to know
what's happening these days not the
economic news anyway that she's already
lived it's terrifying I'm scared for
those families I'm scared for the
children in the clear bin we have dirty
laundry autumn and her younger brother
were those children two of the 16
million living in poverty after the
Great Recession so you're really not
heating up food so much you're eating
out of cans their mother died when they
were young and their father had lost the
family house in Seminole County Florida
by the time Scott Pelley caught up with
them in 2011 for 60 minutes they were
living in this yellow delay
every truck what's that like it's an
adventure
yeah that's how we see it when kids at
school ask you where you live what do
you tell them when they see the truck
they ask me if I live in it and when I
hesitate they kind of realize and they
say they won't tell anybody
yeah it's not really that much of an
embarrassment I mean it's only life you
do what you need to do right where did
that poise come from it came from hope
it came from hope for a better future at
what point did you realize that wow a
lot of people have seen this now
and a lot of people are trying to get in
touch with me that same night that same
night maybe 10 15 20 minutes after our
section ended there were people in our
community who drove up and said hey we
wanted to give you some things that was
when it really hit for me that there are
people who who are out there who really
do care still one of those people was
the president of Stetson University who
noticed our time wearing a secondhand
Stetson shirt in the report and offered
her a full scholarship it was incredible
and it honestly changed my life but she
still needed to get in after her father
lost custody she bounced around foster
care families and very nearly gave up if
you had dropped out of school and
disappeared under your problems people
would have understood in fact that
probably is the expectation for a lot of
kids in your situation absolutely I know
a lot of children who have done that
instead at 17 artim was adopted into a
large and loving family
you encouraged her to get back in touch
with Stetson which she did
were you known as the girl on campus
from the 60 minutes report or did you
arrive completely anonymous blending in
with the crowd oh I totally blended in
with the crowd 100% and that's the way
you wanted it that's how I wanted it I
mean a part of me did want to update the
world that I finally made it and I was
here
but at the same time like I just I just
wanted to be a normal kid but last year
as a junior she decided she was ready to
stand out again at a major conference on
homelessness one of her mentors
professor Raja nee Shankar Brown
introduced a familiar 60 minutes report
and then a certain young woman was
amazing just because it took so much
strength for autumn to have to come out
right and to have to share that story
and to be vulnerable in front of
hundreds of people we had everybody in
tears but in a good way because hearts
were open this month nearly 10 years to
the day she first moved into that truck
autumn hope Johnson graduated on the
Dean's List and with plans to continue
on to law school were there ever moments
when you were there on that beautiful
campus when you couldn't imagine that
the girls sitting on the floor of the
delivery van doing her homework could be
the very same girl on that campus I
couldn't imagine it it was there are
times where I look back and I'm like I
shouldn't even be here but I know that
this is a gift and I've learned to
accept gifts and I'm thankful for it
isn't that lovely she was very wise
beyond her years as a 15 year old back
in 2011 and as you can hear that final
moment there she is still wise Gail and
Anthony autumn says that the lesson in
her story is that homelessness is not
the same as hopelessness and that
education it's a cliche but it's true
really is a ticket out we should mention
that her brother who you saw there in
the clip also doing well also at Stetson
he's now a sophomore and people who saw
the original 60 minutes report may
remember that autumn was called erielle
that is true but her adoptive family
gave her a new name when she started her
new life and I want to underscore Gail
that that middle name there is hope and
I think that's what she personifies yes
I caught that I caught that Toni I loved
everything about this story I was so I
was wondering what happened to the
brother so I'm glad you you gave us the
update about that and I'm thinking this
is not the last time we've seen
I'm hope Johnson she's going to law
school I can't wait to see her future is
really endless
what a great story happy for her yeah
absolutely true you know
go ahead go are Anthony no I was just
gonna say it so you talked about getting
she talks about getting gifts and being
willing to accept them and she got two
huge gifts one of course from Stetson
but from other other from the family
that adopted her and it's that's really
powerful stuff yeah so important to
point that out actually I'm glad you
mentioned it good on Stetson from making
the promise and then years later
delivering on that promise and and for
autumn's to follow through so it's a
beautiful ending to a story that could
ended very differently all right and you
can see Scott Pelley 60 minutes story
featuring autumn this is the the the
initial report about autumn and her
brother it's at 60 minutes overtime
dot-com